في ابرز التطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا اكدت هيئه اركان الجيش
الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه تواصل
محاولات التقدم نحو مدينه بخموت رغم
الخسائر التي تتكبدها وقالت الهيئه ان
القوات الاوكرانيه صدت اكثر من 70 هجوما
على محاور القتال خلال ساعات الماضيه كما
اكدت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه شنت هجمات وصفتها بالفاشله نحو
منطقه مارينكا جنوب دونيتس بينما شهدت كل
من
وشختر بمقاطعه دونيتسك وقبيانسك في مقاطعه
خاركيب محاولات اختراق لخطوط الدفاع
على موقع ريبار العسكريه الروسي ان قوات
فاجنر تواصل الضغط على القوات الاوكرانيه
في بخموت من الجهتين الشماليه والجنوبيه
للمدينه في مسعا لتطويقها من كل الاتجاهات
واضاف الموقع ان قتالا عنيفا يدور في بعض
الاحياء وسط وشمالي المدينه مشيرا الى ان
اعنف تلك المعارك تدور داخل المنطقه
الصناعيه وفي بلده اريخوفو باسل يبكى شمال
غربي بخموت
نتابع هذه التطورات مع مراسلينا من كييف
حسن الشوبكي ومن موسكو امين درغامي اهلا
بكما ابدا معك حسن فياب واخر التقارير
المرتبطه بتطورات العسكريه سيما في مخموت
وكذلك ان كانت هناك اي تصريحات سياسيه
سجلت
[موسيقى]
نعم يعني يمكن القول ان
عمليه الانزال التي تحدثت عنها
الجانب الروسي الذي تحدث عنها قبل قليل
على سد كخوفك هذه تتم يعني العمليات الضرب
من الجانب الاوكراني والقوات الاوكرانيه
في يعني غرب نهر دنيبرو من منطقه ليمانسك
التي يتم القصف منها وهنالك محاولات انزال
تتم من وقت الى اخر على الطرف الاخر لسد
كخوفكا وهنالك يوجد محطه كهرومائيه وهذه
المحطه يعني تعتبر حيويه واستراتيجيه
كبيره بالنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه
المحاولات لا تتوقف حتى اللحظه لا يوجد رد
من طرف السلطات الاوكرانيه حول محاوله
الانزال التي وصفتها الجهه الجهه الروسيه
بانها يعني محاوله فاشله وانه تم احباطها
من طرف القوات الروسيه على صعيد باخمه
الحديث عن يعني
واربعين غاره يعني 24 اشتباكا وهنالك تحسن
لقوات الاوكرانيه في غرب نهر محمودكا
وايضا هنالك يعني هجوم تم منذ الصباح
لمناطق قسطنطين وكذلك للطرق على باتجاه
كراماتورس الهجوم لا يقف هناك وهذا الحديث
على لسانه متحدث باسم القياده العمليات
الشرقيه
الذي قال ان
225 قتيلا في القوات الروسيه سقطوا في
المواجهات في هذه المنطقه اضافه الى 306
جرحى هذا ما افاد به شرفاتي وهنالك
تاكيدات من طرف الاستخبارات
البريطانيه ظهرت ايضا
ظهر اليوم وتؤكد بان القوه الهجوميه
للقوات الروسيه وامريكياغنر هي في اضعف
حالاتها مقارنه بما كانت عليه في شهر
يناير الماضي
ورجحت الاستخبارات البريطانيه ان ذلك يعود
الى سبب النقص في الافراد والذخيره وان
المحاولات مستمره من الطرف الروسي لاعاده
يعني تزويد هذه المنطقه
بالمزيد من الافراد والذخيره حتى تتمكن من
الهجوم مره اخرى لكن الوضع الحالي هو
تحصينات في من الطرف الاوكراني والدفاعات
من في الجانب الغربي بالاضافه الى عمليات
هجوم وكرر وفر من الطرف الروسي ومنظ على
الصعيد السياسي يمكن القول ان هنالك يعني
حديث متواصل هنا في كييف عن اهميه زياره
الرئيس الصيني الى روسيا الاسبوع المقبل
وكان هنالك لقاء او اتصال هاتفي ما بين
وزير خارجيه اوكرانيا الديمتركوليبا مع
نظره الصيني يؤكد له على صيغه السلام
واحياء اعاده السلام العادل والشامل لكل
اوكرانيا ووحده الاراضي الاوكرانيه هذا ما
طرح الخارجيه الاوكراني مع نظيره الروسي
الصيني في الاتصال الهاتفي وكان هنالك
ايضا تصريحات للمستشار في الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه ميخائيل بودلياك الذي قال ان
الصين كلاعب عالمي يعرف كيف ينهي الحرب
ولكنه قال ان هنالك محادثه محادثه محتمله
ما بين الرئيس
الاوكراني والرئيس الصيني لكنه لم يفصح عن
تفاصيلها لكن قال ان الصين تعلم جيدا كيف
تنهي هذه الحرب في موسكو ما ذكرته السلطات
خرسون المواليه لروسيا عن اغراق بارجه
عسكريه اوكرانيه كانت تحاول عبور سد كخوفك
على نهر الدنيا كما قالت ما هي التفاصيل
التي توفرت بخصوصه
اما صحيح مريم هذا ما جاء على لسان حاكم
مقاطعه خرسونه الموالي لروسيا فلاديمير
سالدو الذي كشف على ان المدفعيه الروسيه
تمكنت من احباط هذه المحاوله التي وصف
بانها الاكبر من نوعها خلال الفتره
الاخيره وقال اذا كان الحديث في المرات
السابقه وخلال المحاولات التي كانت تتكرر
تقريبا بشكل شبه اسبوعي من قبل الجيش
الاوكراني لعبور نهر النيبرو الى الضفه
اليسرى التي كما نعلم يسيطر عليها الجانب
الروسي كانت تقتصر فقط على مجموعات صغيره
للقوات الاوكرانيه قوات الانزال وعبر
قوارب وزوارق عسكريه صغيره فانها الان
الحديث يجري عن بارجه وقال بانه تم اغراق
هذه البارجه بضربات للمدفعيه الروسيه وقدر
ان تكون خسائر الجيش الاوكراني في هذه
العمليه
بالعشرات طبعا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه كانت
امس قد نشرت صورا
استهداف يعني ما يعتقد انه زورق عسكري
اوكراني في نهر النيبرو لكن لم تتحدث عن
حجم الخسائر التي خلفتها تلك الضربه
ويعتقد ان تكون تلك الصور هي لهذا او هذه
العمليه التي يتحدث عنها الجانب الروسي
والتي تم احباطها اليوم منذ فبراير من
العام الماضي اي منذ انسحاب روسيا من
المناطق التي كانت تسيطر عليها في الضفه
اليمنى من نهر النيبرو الى الضفه اليسرى
من هذا النهر وهناك تقريبا محاولات تتكرر
باستمرار اضافه الى القصف المتبادل بمختلف
انواع الصواريخ
والقذائف بين الجانبين وهناك ايضا كما
نعلم اتهامات متبادله باستهداف بعض
المناطق السكنيه كالوشا ونوفايا كخوفكا
وبعض المدن القريبه من نهر النيبروب في
باخموت اليوم هناك حديث عن ان قوات فاجنر
ما زالت تحاول الضغط على القوات
الاوكرانيه داخل المدينه من الجهتين
الجنوبيه والشماليه كما اعلن عن ذلك موقع
ريبار العسكري الروسي المتخصص وقلبي ان
اعنف المعارك تدور داخل المنطقه الصناعيه
الحديث الان عن مصانع للصلب والحديد في
هذه المدينه وهو طبعا ما يحيلنا الى معارك
سابقه شهدتها عدد عده مدن في اقليم دومباس
كانت تحتوي على نفس المناطق وايضا على
مصانع للصلب والحديد ومناجم للفحم باعتبار
ان هذه المنطقه معروفه بانتاج الفحم
والصلب وكانت دائما هذه المعارك اذا
تذكرنا كما حدث في ماريوبل او في مدينه
كانت تستمر لاسابيع واعاده ما تتميز مثل
هذه المعارك
بنوع من العنف وايضا بنوع من القصف
المتبادل بين الجانبين الذي يطول لاسابيع
في افدي قريبا من مدينه دانياس كالموالو
لروسيا هناك يتحدثون عن تقدم باتجاه بلده
كراسنا غوروفكا في محاوله عالميه يبدو من
القوات المواليه لروسيا لقطع احد اهم طرق
الامداد الى هذه المدينه اي مدينه ارديف
التي لطالما تهم المولو لروسيا الجانب
الاوكراني باستهداف مدينه دنياس كالمدينه
الاكبر في اقليم دوباس وعاصمه هذا الاقليم
استهداف الاحياء السكنيه انطلاقا من مدينه
افديفكا امين درغامي من موسكو وحسن شوبكي
من كيف شكرا جزيلا لكم